hi there I'm an oppressor Robinson for
gamespot and I have stumbled upon a
particularly dashing group of pro gamers
from Team Evil Geniuses will you guys
introduce yourselves for me my name is
Eduardo PR Boris I was Kenneth k Brad
Bradley hi my name is ricky ortiz my
name is justin wong and for those people
who may not be familiar with you what do
you do for a living i play fighting
games for a living and uh yeah so as pro
gamers you're here at a conference
that's completely devoted to games what
is that like I'm losing my mind right
now you know my first time here so just
looking at everything is pretty sick
this is your first time here so just
walking through those doors a minute ago
is the first time you've been at e3 yeah
I was screaming I was like yelling at
everybody you guys were kind of near the
front of the line how early did you have
to get here in order to get through that
path uh we got here look around 11-ish
so we were there for me with about an
hour yeah just hanging out what are you
most particularly interested in seeing
do you think I want rid of that Nintendo
booth actually I'm pretty excited to see
that yeah yeah what about you Justin
what are you most interested in seeing
since I'm a fighting game player I would
like to see killer instinct season 2
super smash brothers for the the wii u
and also Mortal Kombat X very nice what
are you hoping to get your hands on and
actually play I think Metal Gear Solid
aside from fighting games do you agree
with that metal gear a metal gear did
you guys see any of the the press
conferences or any of the big
announcements that came out um I didn't
get see I still do a lot of it actually
I want to see it but i'll check up on it
later guys got well it's nice it keeps a
kind of a surprise you know you can come
into the booths and be well yeah totally
yeah great now are you guys gonna be
here all three days you only get one day
to check it out what do you think um
we're gonna be working at the capcom
booth so we're going to be playing
against each other playing against
people and there's going to be an
invitational tournament all for four of
us will be part of it awesome so if
somebody wants to get involved in that
tournament and come play against you
guys what should they do they should go
to the capcom booth look for evil genius
shirt
to okay Brad he sucks oh oh you have a
rhetoric for that no I suck just a long
set it so it must be true so this is
this is the sure you're looking for the
evil geniuses shirt right here there do
you think anyone has a chance of beating
you guys oh no evil genius the best team
through so no one could beat us are you
looking forward to the competition with
fans and stuff or is it kind of like you
know just easy to bop these these guys I
mean I'm not gonna lie it it might be
hello be easy but I'm trying to but my
teammates and you know some
internationals are coming so you know
it's gonna be good so come check us out
being pro gamers you know this is your
livelihood you're coming here you're
checking out these games does this feel
like a vacation cuz you get to see some
of the games that you would play for fun
or is it still you know it's work at its
core um I think it's a little a little
bit of all I'd say I say vacation mainly
because for me I haven't been to e3 for
about ten years yeah I actually came to
eat 31 they were CBS 2 beta testing yeah
so it's actually a little bit more of a
case for me but I'm excited to play in
the capital thing for sure yeah what
about you Justin vacation or work or a
little bit of bull it's a little both
obviously we're here for capcom but
before that i'm gonna be around
everywhere and I see smash for the other
side right now so I'm trying to play
some smash you know we've seen a lot of
growth out of the eSports community
lately and you see it appearing more and
more in the the dialogues with
developers that they're trying to make
these balance competitive games do you
think we're going to continue to see
that at e3 um probably for other games I
don't think smash I think they said that
smash isn't gonna be as competitive as
it was and mailing but in the back
versions but [ __ ] I mean every time we
keep finding new things are competitive
so we'll see we'll see well thank you
guys so much for taking the time to talk
to me sorry I took you out of your
awesome spot in line but hopefully you
can get a good a good shot at smash
brothers right over here and have tons
of fun guys thanks thank you
you